y'all a cute ass couple how long you
been together
why y'all still look this good you got
kids five nah something is weird yo I
gained three to four pounds a year every
year since I met my wife that's how this
knows I'm faithful I'm not gonna
look good for the rest of these
out here I'm not cheating on my wife I'm
cheating on my diet quite a bit what do
you do man you must make money
aggressive front if I've ever heard it
he owns his own business you know how I
knew could not just cause you're good
because you got all these buttons
unbuttoned that's rich man's confidence
that's the reasonable unbutton right
there one at the top right here just
unbutton that no no I don't do that now
you're looking like you cheat on your
wife no I know you're faithful bro I
don't trust this guy at all too many
buttons unbuttoned and too good at